okay so
good that this this works well
thank you thank you very much for the
invitation and i'm very glad to be here
in prison again
so
today i'll compare what we know about
sum of squares lower bounds uh to what
we know about low degree polynomial
lower bounds
as so in this in this talk i'll first
give some introduction i'll then
describe how low degree polynomial lower
bounds are related to sum of squares
lower bounds i'll then describe our
current knowledge about small squares
lower bounds and if there's time left
i'll try and give some intuition for the
low degree conjecture
as a note this talk is closely connected
to prasad's fourth boot can't talk
but it and from a different perspective
okay so i'll be moving at a risk pace
but please feel free to stop me if you
have any questions
okay so first first introduction
so today we'll be considering
distinguishing problems where we're
trying to distinguish between a random
and a planet distribution
for example in the plant clique problem
the random distribution is just a random
graph where each edge is there or not
there with probability one-half and the
plan distribution we take a random graph
and we plant a clique of size k in it
another example is tensor pca uh where
in the random distribution
uh the ten the entries of the tensor are
just random noise
and
in the in the plan distribution we have
the random noise plus
uh rank one component
okay so here so here's an example for
for planet creek
so
you hear one graph in the random
spin distribution one graph from the
plan distribution okay okay can you can
you tell which graph has has a five
clique
to just call it out if you see it or
take a guess
have more edges that's actually the one
on the right
yeah it's it's it's not a
immigration release an optical illusion
because the the the one on the left has
its edges are hidden on the outside
between tops
i i did previously but then this is
actually uh
the same from my from my last iteration
of the of the sum of squares uh of
course a few years ago
uh
okay let me uh
okay so
anyways in in the low degree polynomial
framework
uh we ask is there a low degree
polynomial which distinguishes between
the two distributions
uh more precisely is there a low degree
polynomial f such that the expected
value over the plant distribution is
large
but the expected value over the random
distribution is zero
and the variance is at most one
and if so then then this then we have a
low degree polynomial lower bound
so in the sum of squares frameworks so
sum of squares is a proof system so it's
most naturally applied to
certification problems
where we try and certify that a random
input does not have have some hidden
structure
that said we can apply it to
distinguishing problems with the pseudo
calibration framework
where so
i won't go into this too much but we
first used pseudo calibration to obtain
pseudo expectation values for the random
inputs
and then we construct the corresponding
moment matrix and then we analyze
whether this moment matrix is psd
and
if it's psd with high probability then
then we have a sum of squares like that
actually more precisely the pseudo
expectation values will satisfy all low
degree constraints satisfied by the
planet distribution
it does exist so you see here here's a
here's a summary
actually
okay so the the low degree conjecture
says that
if we have a sum of squares lower bound
where the pseudo expectation value of
one is as well behaved and
yeah i'd say
the first time it squares lower bounds
the two expectation value of one is
pretty much always well behaved
then
then this implies a low degree
polynomial lower bounds as as i'll
discuss next
so to look into the low degree
conjecture
is for the other direction it's it says
that
the conjecture is that for symmetric
distinguishing problems
if we have a low degree polynomial lower
bound
then we'll have a sum of squares lower
bound for a noisy version of the problem
where we add some additional noise to
the planet distribution
okay so before i move i move on to the
next part are there any questions you'd
like to ask now
could you could you review briefly
for folks what it means for pseudo
expectation of one to be well behaved
and so i'm gonna talk about that in the
in the next
okay so
i'll now
i'll now just describe the uh the
relationship between low degree
polynomial lower bounds and sum of
squares lower bounds
uh
proved using pseudo calibration
in particular low degree polynomial
lower bounds correspond to the pseudo
expectation value of one uh being well
behaved
okay so
he observed that the pseudo expectation
value of one is the low degree
likelihood ratio
for the input being from the plant
distribution
so
what what i'll show in this part is that
if there's a low degree polynomial
which has
whose expected value is large on the
plan distribution
and if
whose variance is the most one on the
random distribution
then the variance of the pseudo
expectation value of one
will be at least c squared
okay so but before i do this i have to
give some uh some background
uh so here
he will have a vector space of
polynomials
we'll have an inner product
on these polynomials which is the
expected value of their product on the
random distribution
and then and we'll have an orthonormal
basis of fourier characters
for the uh for this inner product
so now uh
for your decomposition has
is just that for any any polynomial f we
can we can we can decompose it as
uh
as the sum of its uh fourier
coefficients times the the fourier
characters
and then
the below the low degree projection
for the low degree projection of f
we just take the loaded the low degree
fourier characters
okay so first
okay i'm going to be a bit hand wave a
bit handy wavy for this part i should
say i should i should try to give a
little bit
some intuition for what
we want to do with the pseudo
expectation values
so our general setup
is
is that we'll have
for these problems we'll have solution
variables corresponding to the planet
structure that we want to try and find
we'll have our fourier characters
on the random input
and so for example in the plan clique
problem
and we can set it up so that we have
uh solution variables x i where we want
that x i is one
if the vertex i is in the planet peak
and zero otherwise
and then our fourier characters
correspond
correspond to sets of edges
where so that they're the products of
the
individual fourier character for each
for each edge which is one if the edge
is in the graph and minus one otherwise
and and these form an orthonormal basis
if you if you look at the expectations
expectation over a random graph
okay so so now for the plan distribution
uh each planet instance will assign
values to the solution variables
and thus assigns a variable a value to
any polynomial
in the solution variables
so now
but unfortunately okay i can't go into
uh going to this to too much but
what we need to do uh
very soon
expectation values
is for french for any for a random
instance i
we have to assign a pseudo expectation
value
of the suit expectation value of p to
each low degree polynomial p
in the solution values
okay
so
so the pseudo calibration technique for
doing this is as follows
given the random input i will take the
pseudo expectation value of p to be the
low degree projection of
the probability
of the plan distribution of having the
instance i divided by the probability
from the random distribution
of the instance i times
uh times p of i
so so the reason that
the the reason that that this works well
is is as follows
so the
if you look at the expected value over
the random distribution of the pseudo
expectation value of p times chi i
so
so here
we just plug in
plug in this expression here
and then
and then observe that this is just equal
to the expected value
over the planet distribution of
p times
times chi i
so what this is saying is that as far
as far as low degree tests are concerned
the expect the student expectation
values over the random input
behave like the
the actual uh
solutions
over the
over the plan distribution
and this uh the this gives us the
following equation the pseudo
expectation value of p
is the sum over low degree chi i
of
the expected value over the plan
distribution of p times chi i
times chi i
so once so once we have the random and
plan distributions it's a mechanical
it's a mechanical process
okay
anything that you'd like to ask so far
in solution
variables right so
p of i means
that there's some solution associated
with instance i
yes so so here the
so for instance from the plan
distribution uh the they'll also assign
uh values to the
uh they'll also assign values
uh to the solution variables okay so
so
all right either
the probability over the plan
distribution of having i will be zero or
like p of i will be will be involved in
fact
hey
can i i should also that as as as a
thesis the
uh
if we didn't take the a loading region
truncation of this then that then this
would be well this would be well defined
but however it would it would be zero
on
almost all instances if it's in
particular it would be zero
on any instances
which uh which are not in the planned
distribution
yes it's easy to verify this is an
actual pseudo expectation like the e of
b squared positive
uh uh not not not at all that that
that's where that's where all all the
technical challenge
uh
all the technical challenge is so that
so yeah there's no guarantee that this
that this will give a valid uh serious
rotation value but it does work well in
in many cases
okay so so what so what
oh yeah say so a canonical example is
there's planet clique where like if we
take the uh
again
the energy distribution where we have a
random graph and the and now take us
we'll look at a slightly different plan
distribution for simplicity
where
we start with a random graph and put
each vertex in the planet creek with
probability
k over n
now if we define
x of b to be the product over i and v
of x i so it's an indicator of whether
all the vertices of the
are in the planet leak
so i claim that the
the expected value over the plan
distribution of x v times chi e
is k over n to the number of vertices
which are either in the or are an
endpoint
of some edge
in e
so the
so the reason is that if
if all these verses are in the planet
clique then
x v is one
and all the edges are present so chi e
is also one
if some vertex uh v is not
if some vertex here is not in the planet
leak then
x v will be zero
and if
if some vertex
if some endpoint of an edge and e is not
is not in the planet fleet then one of
these edges will be outside the planet
clique
so it'll have expected value zero over
the randomness of the rest of the graph
outside of the planet quake
so the uh so the so these give the the
following pseudo expectation values
okay so next and that so now let's let's
analyze uh the pseudo expectation value
of one
so this so here's the
pseudo
calibration equation
so as a special case the pseudo
expectation value of one will be one
plus the sum over uh
not an empty low degree chi i of the
expected value
over the planet distribution of chi i
times chi i
and now
let's assume that we have a
low degree polynomial f
such that the expected value over the
plan distribution of f is is c
the expected value or the random
distribution of f is zero and the
variance of f is
is at most one
so now uh he uh he uh
uh here's the proof
and the note also all sums of blue will
be over low degree uh non-empty chia
so
but let's write f has the sum somewhere
over i of
a i times chi i
and let bi be
the expected value
of the plan distribution of chi i
so now the seed expectation value
of 1 minus one will be
uh
uh by this formula it'll be the sum over
chi i of bi times chi i
so now the variance of f will be the sum
over
over i of a i squared
and the variance of the pseudo
expectation value of 1 will be the sum
over i
uh bi squared
and now using koshi schwartz
is the expected value over the plan
distribution of f
since f is the sum over i of a i times
chi i this will be the sum over i of a i
times b i using koshi schwarz this is at
most
the square root of the sum over i of a i
squared times the square root of the
square root of the sum over i of bi
squared
which is the variance of f times the
variance of the pseudo expectation value
of 1.
now
since the variance of f is at most one
rearranging this this gives us that the
variance of the pseudo expectation value
of one
is at least c squared
okay so
all right he he he has a picture for how
how low degree polynomial lower bounds
are related to some of the squares uh
lower bounds proved using pseudo
calibration
uh right so the uh logically polynomial
lower bounds uh correspond to checking
that that the particular entry the
pseudo expectation value of one
is well behaved uh whereas for a sum of
squares lower bound uh we have to show
that the entire matrix
is psd uh with high probability
so
okay so this means as so sum of squares
lower bounds uh using cedar calibration
are strictly stronger than uh low degree
polynomial lower bounds as they involve
analyzing the entire matrix and there
are many interesting techniques involved
improving sum of squares uh lower bounds
which i could talk about for
for a long time but that now and then
that was not that time
that said low degree polynomials are an
excellent heuristic for determining the
computational threshold where a problem
is hard and they're much they're much
easier to prove than low degree
then uh that's that should be some sum
of squares a lot of times
okay so uh
any questions before i move on to the
next part where
well this i'll describe what uh what we
uh what we currently know about
i
describe current gaps between sum of
squares and lower bounds and low to be
polynomial lower bands
that's
yeah um is it easy to see that there's
special case the zero expectation of one
on the previous slide so
yeah is it easy to see the second line
yes that is
that's why this uh this vanishes
and then uh when chi i is
does the empty sets then
uh
itself is also is also just one so that
that that's why that's why we just have
the the the one term next yeah
that should be sufficient for the the
third part uh
but probably won't have time for the for
the uh
for the fourth part
okay so
yeah so
uh so far that there's a lot of evidence
for the for the reconjecture
the thresholds first uh sos lower bounds
and low degree polynomial and
uh logarithmic polynomial lower bounds
match for uh natural planet clean tensor
pca uh sparse pca
and and
random
csps uh that said there are still
significant gaps between known srs lower
bounds and known low degree polynomial
lower bounds
okay so here's uh here here's one subtle
issue which is that currently
uh current sos lower bounds are delegate
as the as they're sensitive to the
choice of plan distribution so for
example for planet clique
the random distribution is g and one
half
the plant distribution we uh we used for
uh in vhk plus
uh
uh someone specialized in plant clique
is to put each vertex in the planet
clique independently with probability k
over n
this makes the pseudo calibration
calculation uh uh simpler but the the
the problem is that this
that
we do
we really want to satisfy the constraint
that the clique has size exactly exactly
k
and this uh
this only uh makes the the planet creek
have size approximately k
so
our desired plan distribution would be
the planet peak of size exactly okay as
an uh so here uh schwab pong recently
fixed this issue by proving a sum of
squares lower bound uh for for the
desired plan distribution
so another another example is tensor pc
uh is tensor pca right so in the random
distribution we have a tensor t
that get gasoline entries
so the the plan distribution uh using
the current in the plan of distribution
using the current lower bounds
the
we take a vector v
where
most of the coordinates are are actually
zero
there's actually somewhat sparse vector
if we instead took v to be a vector with
coordinates plus or minus
one over square root of n and for an
annoying technical reason which i won't
get get into
uh the current techniques
uh from analyzing the mole matrix don't
quite work
okay so
i'll now describe uh two interesting
examples so one one is something which
i've heard called
called parallel pancakes
another is independent set on sparse
graphs
so consider the following random and
plan distributions
for the amino distribution distribution
uh we have m random vectors
uh in our n with
with gaussian entries and the plan
distribution
so we'll we'll uh
we'll first uh choose a hidden direction
uh v
and then
we'll choose uh
and that there'll also be
some distribution a
and then
and then what
we'll test our m vectors so that
with uh orthogonal to v
uh they're
the the they're nice and they're nice
and gaussian
and
and in the direction v
uh they're
they're distributed according to x
okay so that there's
this uh
uh
this
this is a basis for the
statistical uh query lower bound on this
problem
where
where if the
if a matches the first k moments that i
i have a gaussian and
and the total variation that uh distance
between a gaussian and it is
is finite then then
the lower bound when m is much less than
n to the plus one over two
and
as it is
it was recently shown
by chancellor and others i apologize i
apologize for without not having the
names on the top top of my head as this
little query lower bounds uh
are very closely connected to someone's
uh to literally polynomial uh lower
bounds
for some squares so
for the special case when a is just a
minus one and plus one
we have we have an sos lower bound when
m is at most end of the three halves
which was used to prove an srs lower
bound for the sharington kirkpatrick
problem
uh as a note uh here here we have a lot
of e polynomial lower bound when m is at
most n squared
one one interesting question is just to
try and strengthen the
the source lower bound from m
from n to the three halves and squared
and another
another open problem is to prove srs
lower bounds for more general
distributions to wrap up just so we
don't lose too much
the last example i'll
i'll give is independent synonyms on
sparse graphs so given as far as graph g
with average degree
approximate average degree d doesn't
have an independent set of size k
roughly n to n over this d to the one
half plus epsilon
so here here we can have the random
distribution via g and d over n graph
so a naive plant distribution is to
start start with this graph and then put
each and each vertex in the independent
probability k over n
the problem is that it's easy to
distinguish these distributions
uh
in fact carrying the number of triangles
is efficient so what what can we do
so relatively polynomials
and
so it's a little inaudible i've recently
got around this
by showing a lower bound to the recovery
problem
uh so showing they showed that
if you uh even though they're these
global distinguishers if you look at a
given vertex i there's no there's no
load to be polynomial which
distinguishes whether
i is in the independent set or not
and
for sum of squares we recently
showed so this table will be posted in a
few weeks
uh that
uh
uh even though the calibration fails we
can we can tweak the pseudo expectation
uh values to prove a sum of squares
lower bound on the certification problem
uh proving that
this random graph does not have
this uh this large independent set
so then open the but no one problem here
is can we find a plan distribution
for independent set on sparse graphs
which is hard to distinguish
from g n d over x okay and i'll
i'll i'll end here
[Applause]
thank you very much for tackling some
hardcore technical material in our in
our first uh minutes um we will see you
all back here at 10 11.
yes